coming with me getting a boat dog I'm
gonna go down river I'm gonna go get
firewood and I'm gonna take my chainsaw
I'm gonna hunt and kill trees and I'm
gonna come back here with some tree
flash come on good girl
the hailstones spend their summer in
Kowalik gathering resources for the
months ahead harvesting firewood is
essential to providing camp with heat
drinking water and food preservation
logs here come from about 20-25 miles
upriver and by the time they get down
here takes him a few years this what I
call a mighty fine log this is a good
dry piece of knotty twisted wood that
has really no carving value no slitting
value if you split it it wouldn't split
and make two halves it wouldn't make a
big twist like a rifle barrel so this
gonna be firewood my chainsaw fired up
we need firewood all the time keep
ourselves warm dry ourselves out because
we've got caribou to dry up pretty soon
there's gonna be seals and it skins and
oil to put away and whatever else we
gather on
a half-caf firewood it's just part of
the process the only time the girls ever
take any notice of my firewood getting
abilities is when there is no wood then
they remember come on dog join me
some nice-looking logs you have there
can't have too much firewood my next
step is putting up a meat rack around
here they call it mini something and we
need a place where you can hang meat up
off the ground away from the dogs we're
not to tie the dogs up soon and keep the
wind and the breeze on them and the
Flies off let's just get her done